okay hello everyone we are doing some
trailing version 13.2 design reviews
12th language here and we are looking at
Astro graphics
so right so we can look at the page
master Graphics or we can look at
examples first of all this is design yep
so Astro styling
yes we're getting these kind of funky
words but it's okay I think it's pretty
clear what it is
right so the idea is to follow us as
closely as we can the Geo model which
has been successful and we need this
wrapper because in the future we want to
Overlay several stylings yeah so we
cannot use just a list
and so the idea I'm working on three
different styles at the moment
so the first one is these what they call
ducks
Sky which is just black sky without the
background image
and um
and oh I see
three gigabytes of a femorous data
so the moons require very large files
yes so I saw something that said we
weren't going to default to be able to
do the moons
um or are we I mean
at the moment I'm I'm adding the moons
because it's nice when you zoom in and
you see the moons but yes it is it
requires a ton of data
because it's
sorry no no but why don't we make it so
that by default I mean if we know that
the the image is going I mean it's just
like in many things including Geo we
make some commitment about what the
image is you know what the resolution is
going to be and we only download you
know to that zoom level or whatever
so similarly here
if we know we're showing the whole Sky
we don't need to show the Obscure moons
of Jupiter
right yes that that's correct at the
moment it's it's
pre-computing them up front
well that's crazy what do you mean by
pre-computing I mean it's pre-computing
in the system or it's pre-computing in
the ephemeris data
well
it's it's kind of preparing itself for
the casing which is used to mean in this
map
and so it's it's actually going to place
them there
you know I think that's a mistake
because I think it's it's like it's like
placing too high a zoom level in Geo
yeah
um I have another question which is have
we looked at whether we can use machine
learning to reduce the size of this
default of femoris ephemorities
I think we should feed that to the
machine learning group and see what they
can do
or somebody should do that as a project
to just see
it even approximately because I mean you
know it's a performance goal Arrow
whatever you know because there are
police people who do not want three
gigabytes of data downloaded for this
yes I mean this is something that you do
once and because we had played before
I I thought you already had these files
but
um well apparently not okay question I
assume these files are in the CDN yes
yes yeah
yes I mean the right thing here is to
have a low Precision model program so
I'm just I'm just going to make a very
trivial point which is that in that
progress monitor yeah it went from 3.21
to you know 3.3 and it jumped because it
didn't have the extra digit we should
whoever's dealing with those progress
monitors Avery I think this is for you
to chase should make sure that it's a
constant number of digits
yeah I got it I'm working on that
project as well okay fine I mean what
should happen is what they should do
it's okay to jump once that is if you go
from
9.99 seconds to 10.0 it's okay to jump
once you just don't want to be
repeatedly jumping
see what I'm saying
from 3.10 3.1 to 3.21 you get what I'm
saying you don't want the number of
digits you can have you can have it jump
between nine and ten that's just one
jump right but you don't want to be
repeatedly jumping as you change the
number of decimal digits
yep I forgot that yeah
okay all right so this is
go ahead yeah I was going to ask you to
to try the manipulate you know
so that's the sky over the period of a
day so that age is ours and so we see
here the The Horizon is the green line
and we see the cardinal signs notice
that this is always done so that you
look up towards the sky so East and West
are reversed
you know I have to say if it is
a if it this is a common thing
to want to have a kind of a moving
planetarium-like experience like this
and by the way I have another question
let's say we wanted to use this data you
know our stuff in the planetarium what
format isn't that a spherical image
story
that has to be converted to a spherical
image to be used there am I right am I
wrong
yeah they have typically they have
slicing software that takes images and
video and typically it requires
production work behind the scenes to
take given media and slice it depending
on how many projectors a given uh
planetarium might have because it varies
from one planetarium to the next so
often requires custom work obviously but
I mean we're planning this notion of a
spherical image
which is kind of ultimately what such a
place would need even if they themselves
deploy it in slices
you see what I'm saying I mean this
isn't a spherical it's a projection into
a flat screen
but and presumably in VR
we should be able to easily convert this
stuff to a spherical image
am I right
yes in fact Jeff and I have played with
some sort of Astro graphics 3D in which
rather than having everything projected
into a plane we just add it into a on a
sphere
that sounds nice but um I I saw
um the spherical image that the image
processing team are creating and and
that's for images so far only so I know
if you require adding all this so the
question that I have is if there is a
standardized need for a you know across
the course of a day
type
star image okay
maybe we need a dynamic Astro Graphics
or something separate thing
maybe we need a dynamic astral Graphics
that allows zooming too
right so having these lighter background
which is why I by default remove the
background image which is in the next
section
it's possible to do all those things
dynamically I mean changing time
changing scale
okay okay all right so
this has what about you know maybe a few
hundred stars or something
um so we have a catalog for 100 000 and
each map has at most a thousand and we
label about 25.
okay
and so then there so the idea is that in
the future we will have images
background but the images are hard to to
handle because they need image
processing in every case because they
change in time
and so this is what wait a minute the
fixed Stars wait a minute you're
changing the perspective on the Milky
Way or something how come it's very far
away
um well when time moves the image has to
move
right
so these this Brown Line you see is the
galactic plane
I see so as the brown line moves then
the galaxy has to move
and because we have a single image in a
rectangular projection we have to deform
it in real time
because the shape changes a lot with
time
why are we caching this
it it it's I mean it doesn't help cash
in I mean users might want arbitrary
dates arbitrary positions arbitrary
frames it's just too much frame I see
okay
and in terms of
a highly compressed version of the Milky
Way image
what level of compression are we
achieving in this I mean I don't know
even how we're storing it what is it is
it a is it a get for it what what is
that actual image it's styles style is
using the same framework as you so we
have up to zoom 8. tiles
so we can zoom in and we see nice and
nicer images I see I see I see very nice
so this is the exact same framework as
you
okay now the thing is that in Geo we do
always want that background image but
here typically the Galaxy is not the
most important thing you are interested
in
tell that to the um
color to whatever the the
um
the various Empires and science fiction
never mind
um
okay so so planets
and and the sun Etc
um if you go down you see an image for
example of what do you see if you zoom
in around the galactic center that looks
nicer that's nice and also when we go
below something like 60 degrees
of range then we add constellations
and and deep space objects
constellation lines
yeah exactly yeah not not the not the
not the illustrations are not on by
default you have to manually turn those
on yeah right we don't want the crab you
know whatever
um okay the term visible Sky especially
when you have things like white sky
visible Sky it just it's hard to
understand that that means visible light
the sky invisible light
um
how can we fix that I don't think that's
a good name I mean radio Sky x-ray Sky
those are okay visible Sky just doesn't
make it for me
um
it could be interpreted to mean this guy
that's currently visible from your
location yes exactly
exactly
it's a little bit more verbose which is
a visible light sky but yeah I don't
think that's gonna make it
um
observed Sky telescopes in our Optical
sky
that's not terrible yeah that might work
yeah
what about just Skye
no because there's too many different
types of sky
is the default one right
and I mean dark sky doesn't make sense
because
doesn't that has all kinds of other
meanings but but um
so that's how I'm calling the default
above
the the black one how about light sky
because it is light we see right
yeah
I think Optical is better Optical sky
light sky sounds weird if you also have
dark sky because I know it sounds like
you're saying a light versus dark
yeah
which are not
which one is is the dark sky thing
this one the one which is black yeah
purely vector no images in the back
in fact one point of discussion at the
end is where they should be dark yeah
exactly as well just well black Sky yeah
would be better well the point is that
perhaps this shouldn't be black black I
have the impression that black is too
excessive perhaps it should be some sort
of dark blue I have examples at the very
end perhaps you want to go to the very
end
at the moment and see this ground and
daylight section
so it's more or less traditional to have
some sort of lining a bit of light
around the the ground around the price
Horizon Haze
exactly
wait a minute this is the Horizon the
green the green line is the Horizon
exactly so why are the stars outside the
horizon
because I I it's kind of a transparent
Earth it helps for example showing when
the sun is going to race because you see
the sun before hitting there
The Horizon
that's really obscure it's a bit of game
yeah
well why not why not color
why not do something that sort of and
generally we're going to need your input
here that kind of
you know
sort of obscures these Corners here
and I would say if you're going to
obscure the corners you should bring
this circle in a tiny bit from the edges
yep
because and then you know we know the
other way in Gray it's some light in the
edges instead of darken like yeah I know
but I don't want to lighten it too much
because that's going to end up being the
main event but I agree with you
particularly if the thing is on a on a
background on a white background here I
think graying you know having these
Corners be slightly you know melting
into the background will be good
I also I don't know why are we picking
these particular colors for these these
um it's purely random
grain for grass but other than that yeah
it's purely random in fact probably
color is not the best thing here it
would be better to have names
like clip
equator
you mean have them labeled yes
and eventually even even with ticks this
could be a good application of access
objects because this these lines have uh
I like the idea of having ticks on them
that's cool
and that would get us out of this NW you
know we could we could mark their the
the ticks around
I think the cardinal directions are
standard it's very useful to orient
yourself no that's fine but I mean I
think we can have ticks in the in in
different azimuths you know as a musical
text so to speak right exactly
going back to the mask we were talking
about for the Horizon I'm not suggesting
this for 13 too but some other
um programs will often allow users to
customize that to their own local
Horizon if they go out their camera and
take a horizon panorama
they can often put that in and make it
look like their local Horizon
it's a bit Advanced for this first
version but that needs spherical image
doesn't it needs projection from you
know you take the picture with your
camera all around
and then you have to knit you know do
image stitching to get it together don't
you yeah unless you have a 360 camera
but yes
well right
but
I mean
what would make it clear
that
okay we need to do some experiments here
with with this to look at what happens
if we produce grayish gray green gray
blue you know for this outside piece
here
then with respect to these colors
I don't see any problem in having
and there's apparently no
standardization in the in the color of
horizon versus what what's the blue one
is that the ecliptic yeah yes exactly
and what's the red thing that's the
equator
that's equatorial plane the equator of
the earth projected out
okay
um Polaris is perpendicular to that
so one could imagine
what would the circles of of altitude
look like
or does that not make any sense
do astrographics of Astro grid lines
automatic
oh
cool
so now why is
Polaris
because this is just cinef
right so so that's the point above not
necessary Polaris in fact the distance
is your latitude
from Polaris exactly if you were at the
North Pole then Polaris would be exactly
I might even understand how to navigate
from a whatever that's cool well it's
the distance it's 90 degrees minus the
distance from the Zenith it's uh it's
the altitude of Polaris is your latitude
right
which is the distance from The Horizon
correct correct it's a 10 degree
increments or what
uh yes
I think so
really
the 10 or 15 whatever well okay but I
mean so and and then there's the
question of marking that presumably on
one of these things here right right
that would be nice too
I mean instead of automatic do quantity
10 degrees 10 angular degrees or 1500
degrees you can choose
is that
okay
that's presumably two numbers right you
can give two numbers there yes you can
but that's 40 degrees I don't know where
it thinks I am
oh look at that 40 degrees fancy that
huh yeah yeah that's something
I never really thought about this okay
all right that's how you know where you
are huh
well and then latitude wise yes
yeah longitude is more complicated you
have to know what time of day it is
now
although this oh I see the time of day
we can get
position of the sun well anyway never
mind exactly yeah let me not try and
learn navigation
for
um okay we need to talk about colors
yes
and what other things other than the
grid lines nothing other than the
horizon line is going to get repeated
correct
there's no multiple ecliptics or
anything
not multiple ecliptic but you could have
several sets of grid lines so for
example asteroid lines in Astro you can
say
a equatorial goes to
10 degrees so in certain in their
equatorial goes to 10 degrees
or identity goes to think yeah there
yes yes
a list yeah not a parent a prayer list
because you can you can have several
sets of grid lines at the same time
oh wow okay but that is profoundly not
working in terms of color yeah indeed so
now that that accumulation point is the
ecliptic pole if you did equatorial then
they would
accumulate around Polaris
because the Polaris is the equatorial
port
okay Jeremy we need different colors
are you with us yeah I I am I was
looking at Photoshop about this masking
let me get back to you
there is an astro grid line style option
and you can select
okay
it's very nice I mean it's very nice and
so
I also wonder that if these are a little
bit too far away from the edge it could
be slightly closer to the Edge
small comments okay let's let's scope
out what else we want to talk about here
so I I think Optical sky
is the most reasonable thing and I would
say minimal sky or something would be
the right one for the case that you're
calling dark sky
I see
or Star sky or something that's not
really right
I would just say minimal sky
um
okay
we want black sky that just doesn't have
any that has only the objects that
you're interested in on it no background
or is that none
no it doesn't none because it's still
black versus white exactly yeah certain
black sky
so what is typical of books well they
didn't want to
have so much ink
so in books you will see the sky in
White and the stars in Black
yeah your colors are usually only ever
shown if you have a black Sky they
almost never see colors when you uh have
a white Sky okay so this will be white
sky here right
it's not well done yet because we're
still showing the colors of the stars
and they don't work well against white
there are two pastels so they don't
stick out well then we we always could
change the colors in that case
what the heck happened there
so that's a reflection so this is
included in refraction and of course
refraction works
has the maximum near the Horizon but
then I deactivate it when it goes below
the Horizon and you see this kink
so that's the that's refraction being
deactivated
that's bizarre do I see that in this
case as well oh gosh I do okay yes
oh that's crazy
if we cover the below Horizon then we
will not see that
fine well in other words but I think you
should you should terminate the line
before terminate that that um uh
ecliptic line before you get there yes
it's I mean we have we don't have good
clipping things but I I will find a way
okay but I mean but why does it not Kink
right at the Horizon why does it go
below the Horizon and then because we
need some refraction Beyond the Horizon
for example the sun is displaced above
when it goes beyond the Horizon okay but
I I think that is profoundly not what we
should be displaying here I mean it's a
very amusing effect but we shouldn't
display it here
now okay so but part of the point you're
making there is we can gray this down
but we don't want to get rid of it
entirely because then we'd lose the sun
below the Horizon so to speak which
might in fact be refracted above the
horizon
right
I think it's nice when you're when you
are studying sunset and sunrise it's
nice to see the sun touching The Horizon
From Below what can we do about the star
colors in the case because I think
pumping those star colors up for this
white background will be really nice
it's just not going to work to have them
pastel like this right the Declaration
is to have them black
yeah but
why don't we do better
we can do better I mean given that is
that just as such is that just a
saturation change or that actually
change the color too much
it's look
I mean
is it the actual color of the star
perhaps not
but it is
I mean look there's a bunch of white
light I mean you know as you go through
the plank Spectrum
I I guess I just don't know I I mean
that that we just have to try it but I
mean whether that is the correct
you know 8 000 degrees
whatever it is for that blue star there
I I don't know we can we can certainly
figure out what that color should be
that's what we are computing
we have taken the temperature of the
starting compute in the correct color
I understand but so but the other stores
are all invisible here so you haven't
adjusted those they need to be more
black you can't even see them they're
white like the sun for example right
notice that you faked the sun because
the sun is not yellow like that right
right the sun and the main effect yeah
so if you fake the sun you can fake the
other stars as well and just pump up
their saturation
mm-hmm
or take them into you know take them
appropriately into a color where they're
going to make sense because they're
white stars right and
they're not going to do well against a
white background
right so we're going to provide a legend
too for the colors what kelvin's there
are we could but okay yeah that's a good
idea
is that mercury that dot there
right by the sun
um I think it's Venus
Mercury I think we have it in Gray just
do a bit to the right oh wow okay
so if I wanted to okay let me ask this
question could I show right around the
Sun is there an easy way to do that
um yes
geodisc right Sun The Entity sign in the
first argument and then select an astral
range of
2 degrees something like that 30 degrees
but now can I say
so that's the ecliptic in blue and you
see many other stars and other things
Venus is in Gray which is bad
considering that yes the colors of the
planets are kind of random right now
okay so that has to be fixed in the
white Sky case what does IC and why is
that gray
the Deep Sky object
or like a Galaxy
um okay
so if I'm now if I now say
uh let's get rid of this
you know it's a certain argument that
Venus should be that the font should be
a bit bigger than the HD whatever they
are okay
and likewise for the Sun
is that disc the correct size what is
the size of the disc of the Sun uh yes
so in the when you see the whole Sky the
sun and the moon are enlarged because
the otherwise they are tiny but then
once you zoom in and they start looking
real size we do use real size and for
example this is important for eclipses
because we do get sun and moon
in the right shape yeah okay exactly if
I go to Venus here
mm-hmm
and I go down here to let's say 0.5
degrees
ah Venus is not a disc yet
do Jupiter
well I mean if I go down to a
sufficiently small size
yes you would see Venus as a disc yes
and it moves
do do even smaller I see
so let's do this
wow
cool
but there aren't any any stars
and nothing was there
was an interesting bias the fact that
you get uh you know when you look at the
whole Sky 100 000 Stars sounds like a
lot until you zoom in and then you
realize how sparse that actually is
where's the ecliptic
Jupiter is not at the ecliptic the sun
is a ecliptic
Jupiter is near the ecliptic but I
understand but it was too far away from
the ecliptic to show for the ecliptic to
show up here exactly
ah I think at a very very loud
resolutions there are no grid lines yet
okay so that's the thing to come that's
it yeah
for Jupiter we show by default the four
main moons so I think you zoomed in a
bit too much
I don't know the angular size of Jupiter
to do 0.1 degree
yeah I mean at some point we should see
the four ones and with a manipulate we
should see we would be able to reproduce
to see the movie
cool
okay
um
you know I wonder if we should have an
option to kind of pump up
the visibility of stuff like this
because I mean you know that shouldn't
be a one you know by in reality that's
going to be a one pixel you know it's
arbitrarily small
but if that's what you're really trying
to emphasize
and by the way that color of Jupiter is
pretty weird
where did that color for Jupiter come
from
some sort of average
[Music]
I see
the right thing would be to Overlay some
sort of
image here
and because we have information about
the orientation rotation Etc you should
do it but easier for the Sun as well
yes yes and the moon the most important
one is the Moon
yes
yeah we should do that
kind of kind of textures
for the sun do we have the image do we
actually have an image which has the sun
spots the car I mean I know we know the
number of current sunspots but do we
have the current Sun image no no can we
get it
I don't know of a place that has a real
time that you know there's sites that
have like snapshots throughout a given
day but they're not real time
but it doesn't change that much does it
during the day
um
I mean some spots I've seen movies where
you can see them moving throughout the
course of the day but uh I'll watch it
yeah
I don't think it's significant I mean I
think I think you know track that
Sunspot I'm sure you can zoom in and see
it but by the time it just they can't
move that fast
the sun's big you know
they can't move at um I don't know what
the maximum speed is it's some I need a
hydrodynamic phenomenon but it's
probably given by some plasma
wave so now we're going to need
more weather data for yeah it's more
it's more like the sun's Corona
injections we have it's more like the
sun's rotation period you see not the
sun spots moving so much oh I see we
know what I mean Sun's rotation hasn't
changed yeah it's 20 25 days Sun rotates
once every 25 days
okay
um all right so let's keep going here
so
um
I'm not keen to do something like this I
think this is unless it Jeremy can't
come up with another solution I I think
this is kind of weird it looks like you
know it's Dawn at the Horizon which
isn't it yeah that's obscuring the wrong
Parts I think the outer is what you want
to yeah more yep
looks similar like what you might see in
see like sky and Telescope they have
every month a you know kind of a view of
the the fall sky or something like that
and their their charts might look like
something like this hmm
now we should look at the history of
that I mean because some of these things
it's like oh you know you always make
the Stars black well that's because you
were printing the thing in black and
white so what else are you going to do
um okay
all right so we need these colors go
ahead yeah and I was going to say that
here we have seen part of this already
so we can go fast here yeah okay
so these yes we have seen the Astro grid
lines too
what's your main planes what is that
yeah so the idea is that there are a
variety of string options or parameters
of the styles that indicate how to style
things and how to
done on and off things yeah so the main
planes are the four main planes
equatorial Galactic
style sheet
yeah but I mean main planes is just kind
of a weird construct so I'm sorry just
just to clarify so we've got black Sky
white sky
Optical Optical sky
but because Minima minimal Optical
minimal sky right normal sky but then
white is also minimal
mm-hmm because you're not having you
don't have a um
see black sky is just the objects you're
talking about but maybe it shouldn't be
maybe none should be just the objects
you're talking about
you know
okay so minimal Skies just maybe it
should be black sky is the minimal case
Optical sky
is the case with the actual
um
image yeah I mean the other possibility
would be like telescope sky
is that that telescopes usually have a
very narrow field of view
um okay
um
I mean is the only difference whether
the whether the Milky Way is there or
not
well that image has a Milky Way and many
stars
many more than we have as vector
I see yeah it's literally made from the
Gaia catalog where it's just literally
made up of all the stars that they've
observed it's enough that it actually
looks like the real sky
it's essentially a rasterize point cloud
maybe it should be called realistic sky
what is the analog in Geo
foreign
not really because satellite comes from
actual images
for example this is not an image I'm
going to assuming you don't see the
galaxies which is disappointing what do
you mean what do you mean
just you mean in this image we have and
and we're going to see nebulas
it's made from the Galaxy Star cattle
I'm sorry the star catalog from Gaia it
doesn't include anything other than
Stars
which is actually an image of the sky
I don't know that thing exists of a
global image containing the whole sky
with good resolution
okay we should maybe look for that
okay but that's a separate thing so that
would be a realistic sky right
it's a bit technical you could say Gaia
sky
no more of an implementation detail
though yeah it's more of an implantation
detail okay so you're saying it has
Stars
Starry Sky
um it's a bit of a weird thing right
because you're saying it's not the
actual view of the sky
it's the view of
stars in the sky right
so we we show how we represent other
elements
what it really is is the galactic sky
it doesn't show anything outside our
galaxy
does it show like the magellanic clouds
yes it does
it show Andromeda no I don't think I
don't think so then I think it should be
called Galactic sky and that would give
people the hint that it's going to show
the Milky Way
it's a good argue a little large
magellanic clouds are not part of the
Milky Way they're satellite galaxies I'm
well aware
but if you say Galactic sky
it's like sky in our galaxy of things in
our galaxy
what do you guys think of that I think
it's kind of a cool sounding name at
least
[Music]
yeah I think Optical scanning Electric
Sky work for me both
I don't like Optical Sky do you mean
Milky Way sky or no I mean I we're not
committing okay you know what I'm saying
yeah although you know factors were
stuck in this particular Galaxy for a
while yeah indeed
um
except for the photons and neutrinos and
gravitational waves we get from
elsewhere
um we may have a neutrino sky at some
point although it would just be the Sun
yes neutrino telescopes now so
see the sun through the Earth and such
right
um we could have a gravitational waves
guy
which would be kind of interesting I
mean if we had the you know a background
image that shows all of the events all
of the observed gravitational wave
events
I mean that would be a good example of
something analogous to Geo raster
actually you know look I mean that would
be a good exercise for all of this
technology is you know presumably there
are coordinates
maybe just write essential and
declination but there will also be a
distance coordinate for all the
gravitational wave events which we could
doesn't it all compile into the same
catalog so if you use an x-ray telescope
doesn't that don't they do sort of
extract
basically the locations yeah but goes
into the same catalog there's you know
there's rice Ascension and declination
but there's also a distance
there's a radial thing which is not
always where very well determined
yeah but but that's the that as far as I
understood the catalog sometimes have
radius sometimes doesn't
yeah
now the thing is that with each
different observation they will observe
objects but then the difficult thing is
to correlate to realize that this object
in this wavelength is the same object in
that Waveland
have higher resolution possibly so
things that in the older catalog were
one thing become two things in the new
catalog so it gets very messy yeah well
welcome to the the
ontology or taxonomy of almost
everything those two butterflies were
used to be one species
and diseases same story yes right
molecular basis for disease all of a
sudden right
okay so let's let's look at this a
little bit more and then we should wrap
up
um
so these are these are sections showing
the various things that we can show
independently so as the guidelines we
discussed
and we can show several at the same time
so this is an example with zebra
then constellations
I think those should be in some kind of
lighter
what are these these are I see this is
the borders of the constellations
and then
where do we get the little animals for
the constellations
you know this looks like the borders of
Africa like someone drew straight lines
for the polygons
yes yeah right
but that but that's what happened
because you know people need to know
it's in Scorpio for example
you know that star that Supernova just
happened somewhere in Scorpio you've
never seen that star before but suddenly
it's very bright
am I am I right about that um
yes they're mainly there for older you
know older catalogs catalog Things based
on their constellation I mean it's not
really that important it's just kind of
a nice orientation you know you want to
know which part of the sky it is and
that kind of narrows it down specified
here the style
yeah
this is a heavy heavily styled version
okay but what would it be by default
well there isn't a default yet there is
a default it's basically gray all gray
okay so what you see up above for Orion
there may Etc I have to look at this
okay I mean show constellations are
automatic or true
well I don't think you should say
constellations I think you should say
show
what is this doing this is showing I
mean you need a name for constellation
images or something so there is
constellation illustration
right so see the style before it says
show constellations illustrations then
that's activating the illustration with
this nice I see
the constellation is just listing which
constellations you want to see because
if you say true it will show all
right
it's quite heavy yeah
right and we just had these custom drawn
right all of these illustrations
yeah we have about 65 done out of 88. uh
we're working on the southern hemisphere
now
huh and there's no like standard we we
basically had to draw them ourselves
because there's no standard right
there's no standard it's pure art
yeah okay there isn't a standard even
for the lines
which lines these lines here yeah
mistake figures yep
I mean some of them are very common you
know everybody has the same view but
others it's like there's variants of
them for some other constellations where
all right okay so what else do we have
is there a bug in that
I see like these radial from the
Pinchers there's these radial lines is
that a bug
with regular lines
so they emanate from the between the two
Pinchers there's a point and then we've
got these radial lines coming out of it
between the Watts the Pinchers
oh yeah the uh
see all these actually there's a few
triangulations it seems to be some kind
of triangulation thing going oh this
thing yeah yeah there's a couple of
places where they're bugs like that
could could be
so these are these are original field
lines
filters sorry in a super scorpion with
it has it has some kind of ray gun as
well as its pincers
I wonder if those go away if you turn
off the transparency yeah they will go
away I'll bet you they're overlapping
polygons
yeah but but we may have to do something
Jeff you know because if you want them
transparent yeah this is a triangulation
yeah this is the this is the ray gun
scorpion I've never I don't know why I'm
not I've never seen that before I this
is my one of my favorite ones to draw
and I've never seen this so that's odd
that we're seeing it here so I'll have
to look closer at that but we typically
did try to avoid overlapping polygon
issues so I'm amazed that we're seeing
this
and that's because what because the the
Scorpion is made of polygons or what
it's old curves
I see
well this looks like a bug
yeah we're looking at that nope
this is pretty nifty I mean so but some
of these things look like they're
distorted and that is that because the
Gaia I don't understand these things
don't look like circular Stars
so there there is the image which may
have been distorted a bit by the
projection and on top of that we put our
stars
and actually we have to be careful with
things like precession because this this
is an image representing the sky in
j2000 in year 2000.
and so they
could have moved
by 0.3 degrees since then
but that's the whole Sky moved it's not
it's not yes the proper motion of some
particular random star
exactly I mean it's something we can
correct but in a sense it will be Faking
It
right because the image is a j2000 image
you know if if the sky is freaking moved
I mean the procession is due to the
change of the frame because the Earth
has processed yes
so I don't think that's faking it I mean
it's like no more than anything else is
Faking it I mean we've changed our point
of view so to speak our orientation
um to say that you're just not you're
not auto-precessing the background is
that correct exactly yep can we
we could we're good yeah
otherwise
this is going to be way out of whack
it's going to have stars you know
Polaris is going to be plopped you know
in one place and there's going to be a
shadow you know like a gravitational
lensing of Polaris somewhere else
and it does happen in some cases we are
not careful with that yeah
right
and if you zoom in you notice it even
more
okay well so we have to get that right
all right
so this is the solar system this is a
this is an eclipse that's going to
happen tomorrow and and this is how it's
going to be seen from lean shopping
that's right
it's uh it's partial everywhere but it's
better viewed from northern Europe so
and I assume I mean you're getting the
order of polygons right in this case
obviously the moon is going in front of
the Sun
good question not always in every case
we have cases of occultations in which
we have the planets reverse and things
like that
this is a functionality that still has
quite a few things to fix but it will be
experiment
are we going to have a scissor juice
function that can find these kinds of
you know occultations and other other
kind of notable orientation you know
notable configurations yeah eventually
for sure we have very precise
data to compute those things
although it's not trivial to find the
system we have to basically do uh some
kind of iteration on the on the
ephemeris yes indeed
but that's why you know it's like it's
not just that it may depend on your
location on Earth over the weekend we
found an example of a planetary
conjunction between Neptune and Venus I
think and it is only visible from the
North Pole
so if you're not at the right place on
the right uh on Earth you don't see it I
see
but in general just like we have find
root we should have fine scissors find
events you know event finding is a big
deal
right exactly
but it's got to be scissor juice because
with auto completion people can even
spell it
I don't know [ __ ] Jews are things in
commutative algebra right
but there are also things they were
originally things in astronomy okay
they're they're these kinds of events
they're these kinds of um
okay what else do we need to look at
here I need to move along here
Saturn should not be green yes
okay we have images of all these discs
and do we know their orientation we do
don't we yes yes it's I mean it doesn't
work and then we are short in time
so the last thing I wanted you to look
at is is the these deep Sky objects
which we don't have images but so we
have representation
so for example
um so these are the stars so these are
fine these
um so keep going on
so this is an example of how we can
scale so if you use this manipulate you
see assuming around Beetlejuice
okay where the size is some kind of fake
it's all the way faked yeah the stars
are very very small based on brightness
yeah
I see
and is it logarithmic or is it is it
just I mean because the magnitudes as
you zoom in you're just linearly
increasing the area or linearly
increasing the linear dimensions
it's it's not exactly linear it's it's
slower than linear
because so if if they would increase too
much if we did it linearly
but but are you doing radius or area
I think I think it's radius
there is a there's a way of controlling
the maximum magnitude that we show this
is another thing that
okay
that's cool I mean so the stars go out
that's nice
I would just say
why do we say show star Max Magnus you
just say star Max magnitude
because not the show it's not showing
the magnitude itself it is the maximum
magnitude yeah I think that's correct in
this case okay I don't think the word
show is needed here
so for example these are galaxies right
so we don't have images for the galaxies
we only have ellipses of where they are
what is that one
is that Andromeda I don't know yes yes
it is
yes the label is a bit too small it's
placed at the center essentially
ha
with it certainly how it fills shouldn't
we fill that
I think it would look better if the
ellipse was filled somehow
some light fill
seems more convincing
okay
given that I mean what we have
presumably
what do we have the semi-major minor
axes and their orientation yep
boy that's big two two degrees really
Andromeda it depends and it also depends
on what you determine to be the outer
edge of the Galaxy the longer your
exposure the more you'll see so it's
always somewhat of an estimate sure if
we had a dark matter telescope we did
maybe I mean there's actually out
tendrils of uh our galaxy and Andromeda
are already touching of course
you know depends on how faint you look
so this is a case in which we show the
background image
because the magellanic cloud is counted
as being Galactic exactly yep well it's
it includes stars that the Gaia
telescope observed so whether or not
they're part of our galaxy or not
didn't see it any stars in Andromeda
um
I don't know off the top of my head
but so if I look at the Crab Nebula for
example so just just for
um
but if I look at the Crab Nebula
if I say astral graphics
let's see what happens if I just do this
okay where is it do you have to say uh
anastro range
now where is the Crab Nebula
it may not be up this is showing the
whole sky
why isn't it indicating the crowd nebula
oh I see this is because we do the same
as in Geo when we have an entity we use
it for localization we don't show the
point
unless I say point exactly if you say
point now this point is going to be a
black point so we do have to say white
also
is that really the right thing by
default
this is something that arnuth had
pointed out that perhaps we should have
a different default but changing a
default like that is going to change
potentially
okay what can I do here if I say disk
can I have a number of degrees here
um the not decrease do I don't know one
something like that I don't so these are
this is projected coordinates so
by the way right now the Crab Nebula is
about 22 degrees below the Horizon so
it's not even up right now right that's
too much so
I see well fortunate that we're showing
things below the horizon
right okay so now
I don't really understand I hope we're
documenting somehow those units
um so let's look at the Crab Nebula in a
astral range
okay now why am I not seeing stars there
do I need to say because it's gas it's
gas it's not made of stars
but there's no image
by default there is no image okay so how
do I put an image in here
as the background goes to visible sky
don't forget the autocompletes by the
way
but it's not made of stars it's made of
gas maybe try to play these
I don't know I know those are stars but
but um
yeah so
how do you spell Pleiades
p-l-e-i
then what uh a d e s
and that's right yes
okay but so that's indicating
consumers yeah
that's a that's big the Pleiades is a
quite large
comparably it's actually 70 degrees
right yeah
okay what's that Circle
that's the boundary the the official uh
angular radius of the Pleiades
one of these boxes those are other
nebulas that are nearby nebula a few
snebulas or rectangles and squares star
clusters are open circles
okay but so this is yet another color
we're gonna need
right so these representations are
aristanda I mean in traditional facts
fair enough
this is really wonderful stuff guys
um I really need to go
the
um
yes
okay so the with respect to the global
Astra project I think the main thing we
didn't fully agree was this breaking the
Astro Observer astral frame
um
Freedom do you remember we were
discussing about uh having separate
of server base
Etc so that that's the thing that I
think is is still missing
two
implement
to that
I'm sorry say that again please
so I'm saying that what we have seen
today is Astro graphics and we will
Implement your changes I think with
respect to the global project Astro
project the thing I think is still a bit
in the air is there is the language for
the airstrap servers or after frames and
I realize that frame is actually not
that good either because it collides
with the frame right
so I think we may still have a bit of
naming design there astral reference
frame
no that's probably totally wrong
is it wrong is it right
after a reference frame
as as concept is is fine
it's a bit long but it will be fine
France would also complete so four
um
then we should go with that
seems to me
okay all right this is great
um
and uh
oh Sanders commenting about with VI
should be able to see The Parallax for
the stars I don't think so one parsec is
um
I mean they're not very many stars but
then
they're you know there are no stars
other than the sun within one parsec
um so we can compute Parallax certainly
seeing it here is more difficult but for
example a bigger effect is aberration
and that's that's very clearly scene in
the maps
that's 48 seconds
due to the motion of the earth is that
right yeah
around the Sun yeah
I see
yeah that one even surprised me Jose had
to show that to me because I had not
encountered that before that was pretty
impressive one of the documentation
examples though
well great time for somebody to write an
astronomy textbook based on this stuff
it would be really nice this is really
clarifying in so many things
um
well great okay I gotta run off
um
uh okay talk talk to you all soon
thanks guys okay